[Music]
the fan base that you have built up over
the years and I said it to in the
commercial break it's because you're so
freakin good you're so it's so good at
what you do the point where now we live
in this era where you've inspired a lot
of creativity with your fans your fans
make jewelry they make I think I think
that where there's a necklace that a fan
made it a lot of it is you eating hot
dogs
I guess you you've made it known you
like hot dogs and so your fans made all
this art that we have drawings I think
of you eating my dog it's a big thing
people let this was sent in today when
an artist found out that you're on the
show and actually it's this was sent in
it's a beautiful sort of artistic
representation of you eating a hot dog
and you think this is all springing up
on the Internet you get these sent to
your home No thank goodness I don't but
I'll tell you I'm not what you might
call a healthiest eater in the world but
I figure I'm not I'm not saying
everybody should eat hot dogs and he
said when he worked with you yeah I
hosted I hosted a game show pilot and
you that you were on and I believe you
had Taco Bell
that was your dinner with Taco Bell yeah
I have to ask you about this Larry
King's we had him on the show recently
and we got into the conversation and he
just brought up apropos of nothing but
he just brought up that his wish was to
be cryogenically frozen
and I thought such a it had surprised a
lot of people I've had people come up to
me on the street and say can you believe
Larry King wants to be cryogenically
frozen can you believe that is that
something that I've heard that before in
fact I'm in fact I've heard it from from
Larry yeah he's kind of obsessed with it
I mean you get you you know he'll say
like might you'll say nice weather and
he'll say I want to be frozen you know
and it's a hard subject to bring up an
ordinary Congress no he doesn't know
Larry doesn't need that he just acts
like I just took a call from Wichita you
know and then he launches into whatever
he's gonna say that's right it was a
nice man from Wichita called them yeah
but is that when it you know is that
that's something that you've liked
because everybody has different thoughts
about these matters is that seem crazy
to you what Larry is talking about well
I my mother had the most wonderful
outlook on death she she just god bless
her she was she was a piece of work
you'd have liked her but she always said
that we know everything you know sooner
or later somebody on the planet knows
about everything but the one thing
nobody knows is what happens that moment
after death so whenever we would lose
somebody in the family or a friend or
something she'd say now he knows the
secret and it took all the fear of death
away it's a very optimistic and it's
true now you know the secret so I'm
getting curiouser and we don't want you
to find out for a long long time but but
it is it's funny every culture reacts to
it differently and I I've mentioned this
before but I come from hardcore Irish
Catholics and they they're upset
obviously at that moment but then they
turn it into an excuse to tell really
funny stories and drink like crazy oh
I'm glad what to the point where we
almost get optimistic when someone goes
we're like we get to drink and that's
the I'm not and I was you know right
like you I'm a little mix up of a lot of
things but I don't have to wait till
then to drink
you don't need an excuse it's not too
bad